going back to being bullied and feeling
may be different in school do you think
that prepared you more so to get in
front of casting directors and being
told well you know you're this type of
you're that type whatever people are
told about who their type is whether
they want to believe it or not and do
you think that helped you because you
know a lot of people realize how thin
their skin is once they get here and
there told certain things and they think
oh I was always told i was this back
home but right i know you grew up here
so but do you think that was a really
good like you'd already had the skin
ripped off yeah I mean I definitely you
need to have a very thick skin to pursue
acting or stand up comedy both you know
both the exam comedy you're in front of
people with just your mic and your words
and auditions you're in front of very
judgmental casting directors who I don't
love the addition process because I
don't think they create an environment
at all analogous to what it's like being
on set and I get the need to create a
pressure situation to see if you can
handle pressure but it's different kinds
of pressure it's negative pressure and
positive pressure and to me that you
know I love pressure on me I'll of
pressure when people are there to listen
or there to know that I'm going to do
what I'm going to do and they're there
to encourage it then that's an energy I
feed off of and so I thrive on asset I'm
acting on a set or hosting something on
set that's my comfort zone but I think
casting directors miss it all the time
because their audition rooms are very
cold and quiet and just meant old
formulas like hi thanks for coming in
and go ahead and I'm supposed to just
act and just like cold sterile
environment by another judging every
second and every moment to see if I hit
that job the right way sigh you're
supposed to receive entertainment or
receive the performance so I know they
find a lot of good acting that way but I
think they must be missing a lot of good
actors that way as well there needs to
be a more fun vibe in an audition room
and you can really see people in their
element confident because when you're on
set yes or time pressure there's money
pressure but there's not a judgmental
energy that I think can affect
performances and I don't even know if I
answered your question at all
you